[Music]
over a year into the kobit 19 pandemic
billions of people have now been
vaccinated
[Applause]
but with the spread of the delta variant
causing cases to rise and the who
investigating over 15 further variants
around the world
this pandemic is far from over
aloc ja and natasha loader are hosts of
the economist's podcast the jab they've
spent the last 18 months reporting on
covet 19 on the global vaccination race
and on the spread of new variants of the
virus
how do you get variants
every time a virus replicates you have
the chance of a mutation happening so
the more it replicates the more chances
for mutation you have and last year
kobe didn't seem to be doing anything
for quite a long time and then towards
the end of the year it started to take
these really big jumps they suddenly
acquired like 20
or more
mutations and the question is is how did
this happen
and the suspicion the strong suspicion
is that the virus has spent um time
inside the body of an immune suppressed
person
where the infection has lingered and
many mutations have occurred within an
individual person so rather than this
being something that happens as it
spreads between people that actually
you're kind of brewing it up in one
place and you can see this happening in
hospitals it's not complete
sort of speculation but if you have a
patient in hospital so they're receipt
receiving um you know some
immunosuppressants and they have a
coveted infection you can watch in that
person as the mutations accumulate and
accumulate this is evolution in action
this is natural selection in action um
we start to
get get on top of the virus the virus
through random mutations finds ways
around whatever mechanism we've found to
stop it spread and ultimately viruses
don't want to be deadly as deadly as you
think that they don't want and when i
say want to have no consciousness
whatsoever but but
if you forgive the anthropomorphism here
uh they don't want to necessarily kill
their house quickly because they want to
reproduce a lot and spread if they kill
their house quickly then they don't
spread um and this is one reason why the
original sars cob didn't go as far
around the world as um as this sarskoff
ii has and so you know the idea is that
even if it's more transmissible it's
definitely more dangerous because it
just means more people get it and
therefore
ultimately the statistics tell you
there's more deaths this is why we are
concerned about variants and should keep
on top of them could the virus mutate in
a way to make vaccines ineffective
[Music]
yeah i mean
absolutely in theory
they could but as time goes on we're
finding that our vaccines are still
protecting against
severe cases and deaths we should start
to feel a little bit more confident
and um
you know if you think about it in 18 uh
months you know the kind of the worst um
variant that has come up has been that
south african variant that seems to um
knock back vaccine efficacy quite a
large chunk whereas the other ones and
the other variants do so it seems
a lot less and so as time goes on
we should feel more confident because
you know we can start to sort of say
well you know maybe the virus doesn't
have as many um molecular tricks genetic
tricks if you like but you know if
something really troubling does emerge
you know we can boost uh with a variant
vaccine that's right i mean i think
right now the vaccines are beating the
variants um but on the on the flip side
to all of that is that um the variants
are really really raging through
unvaccinated people and most of the
world is unvaccinated the more times
this this virus can go into people and
multiply and
sicken more people the more times it can
mutate the more the more evasions it can
have of different um vaccines and of
course i don't think that we're going to
be in a situation where we're as
vulnerable to the the virus as we were
in march 2020 when there were no
vaccines and no treatments and everyone
have to sort of
sit at home all the time
but the longer we leave it that we that
the most the world is not vaccinated the
more chances there are that there's
going to be just another [ __ ] in each
specific vaccine's armor to the point
where one or two of them may become less
useful the race to vaccinate the world
is by no means over and actually it's
the thing it's now logistics to make
sure that we don't get to the point
where the um the
there's a variant as there's
an omega variant that kind of um
rages through even vaccinated people
that will be the nightmare scenario
what do you think humankind will learn
from this global disaster
how to make vaccines really quickly um
viral surveillance i think we'll get
really good at that i think we'll learn
to take tighter control of
lab security and animal food plants
and how to unmute on zoom i think we
have learnt how to do that there's
something i hope we learn i hope we
learn to
try and understand and predict
where these sorts of threats uh from
from the natural world come from
my um hunch is despite all of the
conspiracy theories out there is still
that this came from um an animal uh host
this virus um
and
i don't think it's that controversial uh
anyway so i think that's what happened
and this is going to increase as we
encroach on habitats as we um
uh go into places where we interact with
animals more i'm talking about humanity
in general and if we're going to do that
which i think we should we should
probably not do as much uh we need to
understand what's out there and having
surveillance of viruses out there um
having surveillance of people in those
situations uh to make sure they're
looked after and the outbreaks don't
spread very far that seems to be a
no-brainer from all of this um
scientists have been warning for decades
that this sort of thing would happen and
even in their wildest speculations they
didn't think it would be as bad as this
um
and so so perhaps we should listen to
those people a bit more
i'm natasha lowder the health policy
editor of the economist
you can read more of our coverage on
kobit 19 by clicking on the link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe